je suis super énervée je pense qu'il y a
un âge à tout et le cerveau il évolue au
fil du temps et je pense que de trois à
six ans c'est trop tôt là elles sont
déguisées en princesse
c'est très bien on en a vu plein des
ateliers comme ça la dernière fois on en
parlait encore d'un autre la personne
elle avait un collier avec des pics des
talons et les boules apparentes je suis
désolé il y a un âge à tout il y a
beaucoup
bien sûr la dernière fois et je pense
qu'il y a le cerveau il évolue dans la
vie tu n'es pas avec un cerveau
d'adolescent ou d'adulte et chacun son
tour et on n'est pas obligé de forcer
les choses et et d'imposer des nouveaux
tic-tac comme ça c'est insupportable
Guillaume aussi est énervé je ne
comprends pas cette mode de vouloir
mettre en relation des enfants avec des
drag queen je suis désolé pourquoi les
enfants ces rencontres cette nouvelle
mode elles n'ont rien d'éducative ces
nouvelles d'arcade les drag queen mine
de rien souvent ça fait référence à une
sexualité débridée que ce soit homo
avec l'homosexualité parce que ça peut
être l'hétérosexualité aussi mais je ne
comprends pas pourquoi on impose à des
enfants qui n'ont rien demandé on leur
fait se poser des questions qui n'ont
pas à se poser et on leur impose ces
rencontres il faut quand même dire la
vérité je suis désolé les drag queen
c'est une microniches ça concerne
peut-être quelques milliers de personnes
en France pourquoi on fait chier tous
les enfants avec ça alors et c'est un
atelier des Turcs qui a eu donc ce
samedi après-midi trois doigts Queen
étaient présentes sur place pour animer
l'atelier ce dernier était destiné aux
enfants de 3 à 6 ans vous Valérie Bénaïm
vous vous non parce que vous vous
trouvez pas que ça pose problème vous
faites un amalgame vous mélangez le
genre la sexualité les drag queen il y a
vous mélangez tout et vous projetez vos
propres fantasmes les enfants ils voient
des personnages qui sont ludiques qui
sont déguisés qui sont colorés qui leur
lisent des histoires
et en l'occurrence
comment tu sais ca 12 15 ans mais pas
tous les ne parle pas à leurs parents
c'est pas vrai
puisque toi tu as fait l'amalgame entre
les l'homosexualité et les drag queen un
Français sur cinq comprend que certains
parents n'acceptent pas leur enfant LGBT
ils comprennent ça un Français sur 10
justifie la rupture totale des liens
familiaux
la Valérie vous êtes excusez-moi
c'est trop jeune en fait laissons les
enfants dans le monde des enfants
peut-être il y a un écrivain qui peut
venir des raconter un livre peut-être
une prof peut-être
parce que j'ai l'impression que c'est
des gens qui sont déguisés
tu dis que c'est l'ensemble
pourquoi des dragons pas de sexualité
tu sais pas ce qu'ils disent tu sais pas
comment le choix était le choix des
livres était avec la bibliothèque moi
j'aime bien moi j'aime bien laisser je
pense que les gens mais les gens que ça
les gens que ça gênent c'est pas le
choix des livres ils s'en foutent pas
lire des livres à des prostituées pour
dire aussi que la France
si tu dis ça pour Guillaume c'est pas
sympa on peut faire tout un mètre
limpotes de plein de gens différents
qu'on voudrait amener dans les enfants
de 3 ans au lieu de les élever de les
éduquer
les enfants ils arrivent en scène 2 ils
savent pas ils savent pas dire ils
savent pas écrire on leur présente on
les fait on les on leur fait lire une
histoire par des personnages qui
ressemblent à des princesses de dessins
animés
c'est pas ludique c'est pour les adultes
c'est pas pour les enfants
d'ouvrir un peu l'esprit on va pas ils
vont pas avoir tous les jours des drag
queens qui vont me dire leur dire des
histoires c'est un atelier pour marquer
l'esprit moi quand j'étais enfant quand
j'étais petit si j'avais eu
l'opportunité de voir de la diversité et
bah peut-être que entre mes 6 ans et mes
15 ans je me serais pas détesté moi-même
d'être différent parce qu'à mon époque
il y avait aucune ouverture personne ne
venait de nuire quoi que ce soit la fin
c'est plutôt pédagogique c'est
intéressant pour des enfants regarde
elle est totalement habillée il est
totalement habillé il est déguisé au
même titre qu'Halloween
c'est l'homosexualité avec grand plaisir
de la drag queen d'ailleurs on ne parle
pas d'homosexualité tu peux être drag
queen et hétéro donc ça n'a absolument
rien
[Musique]
de particulier
mon oncle voilà ça se passe très bien
sur lui bien sûr je l'embrasse un Pitou
de Saint-Denis
tu te serais senti mieux dans ta vie si
tu avais vu les diversités mais on peut
en parler on peut dire qu'on est ouvert
à tout et que tout existe et que c'est
accepté bien évidemment mais tu es pas
obligé visuellement de montrer des
choses vulgaires
pourquoi ça te dérange de voir un homme
déguisé en femme parce que tu as peur de
la dernière fois
que les enfants se disent que les
enfants disent ah ben j'ai un problème
avec ma virilité c'est ça et viril on
s'en fout je trouve un homme déguisé en
femme ou un homme déguisé en Scream
halloween c'est la même chose
et c'est vrai qu'ils ont pris c'est vrai
que Raymond les prostituées quel rapport
voilà vraiment il parle juste de ça de
son expérience voilà qui n'a rien à
faire bien entendu dans cette émission
et faire revenir tout le monde faisons
venir tout le monde de ce que tu connais
on comprend bien c'est vrai que tu
connais mieux les prostituées et cet
endroit bravo à toi mon Raymond euh oui
madame madame il faut arrêter avec
l'hypocrisie c'est un atelier de lecture
de 3 à 6 ans et le thème c'est l'égalité
des gens et ça vise à la déconstruction
des stéréotypes et porte sur
l'acceptation de soi et des autres hein
ça pose un peu je suis désolé la
déconstruction
excuse-moi mais pas les enfants
formaient un drag queen à 15 ans ça
n'existe pas ça sert à ouvrir à
l'acceptation des autres est-ce que tu
peux entendre alors
s'il te plaît
idéologie
on apprend ou quand je dis stop c'est
stop sinon ça va pas aller mamie aussi
je suis désolé
des participants qui disait qu'en fait
c'était et ça je trouve le combat génial
justement pour gommer les différences
pour faire comprendre aux enfants c'est
formidable mais à ce moment-là faisons
venir de jeunes homosexuels qui vont en
parler qui vont dire qu'ils ont été
harcelés à l'école
s'il te plaît avant qu'on aille plus
loin je voudrais voir la vie des
téléspectateurs
86%. mais évidemment d'abord la question
c'est compromis que ça pose problème
alors il y a sali il repose sur la
question
parce que comme comme le truc mais comme
on mélange comme effectivement tu
mélanges beaucoup de choses moi je
comprends qu'il y a des parents moi ton
enfant vient de voir dis voilà à l'école
il y avait une dame enfin une dame ou un
monsieur avec de la barbe habillé en
princesse il y a peut-être des parents
qui ont pas les mots pour expliquer les
choses aussi des des parents qui sont
complètement décontenancés par parce que
leur dire on va où les questions que
vous posez leur enfant honnête mais oui
si oui absolument pas compris
j'ai rien compris
moi il était des parents qui vont être
mal à l'aise pour expliquer oui
je comprends que ça pose problème il y a
des parents qui ont qui ont du mal à
expliquer à leurs enfants ce qu'ils ont
vécu lors de cette lecture ben oui bah
écoutez si vous comprenez rien euh
faites un effort
personne personne ne les oblige mais je
comprends pas tu es fou quoi personne
les oblige à y aller je veux dire ce
sont les parents c'est les parents
soient éduquer leurs enfants
différemment qui est une certaine
ouverture d'esprit moi je trouve ça
génial
l'information ou les ou les widir donc
en l'occurrence personne ne te force à y
aller donc je comprends pas que ça pose
un problème tu décides amener ton enfant
moi je pense que tu veux vulgaire mais
le truc qui est assez que ça peut poser
problème aux parents d'expliquer aux
enfants
il va emmener ses enfants non mais moi
je sais pas ce que je sais pas quel mot
je pourrais trouver pour expliquer un
enfant
vous pouvez aussi entendre moi je trouve
que vous pouvez aussi entendre qu'il y a
des gens qui qui soit mal à l'aise
devant une situation
décontenancés c'est des gens qui soient
j'aimerais avoir Géraldine Benjamin il
est mal à l'aise parfois sur la tête
j'avais peur de quoi en fait vous avez
ces enfants qui assistent à ces ateliers
sont assises
qui se suicide qui s'automutile qui
fasse peut-être
vous regardez ces gens on a l'impression
comme des malades ou des pestiférés je
vous assure c'est très choquant
c'est-à-dire que je trouve que malgré
tout et je j'ai bien vu le sondage et
une méthode absolument pas je trouve que
même presque dit 13 % pour le oui ça me
paraît même beaucoup aujourd'hui vu
qu'on est dans une société complètement
réac et limite lgbt-fobe
c'est pas dire ça mais je le signe je
persiste
pas pour nous on les adore voyons en
homme de trois ans
je ne parle
d'une société
entre les drag queen et la sexualité ça
n'a rien à voir non
mais non parce que sinon comme tu l'as
dit tout à l'heure
c'est très bien qu'on dise qu'il faut
respecter qu'on peut être homosexuel
c'est très bien mais les drag queen
c'est un phénomène c'est pas du tout
s'il vous plaît je vais vous dire ce que
disent euh les les personnes sur les
réseaux on va voir le sondage dans un
instant il y avait tout à l'heure
c'était rien et maintenant Twitter
c'est rien on a on a on a des
téléspectateurs on a dit on a des côtes
à trois quand tu as trois la tape à
trois votes je te le dis on a 6 millions
de d'abonnés sur Twitter donc quand tu
verras fait des petits sondages tu
verras la téléréalité est-ce que on se
mettra dans tous nos états si notre
gamin de 7 ans il tombait sur la Villa
des cœurs brisés avec une mini-jupe une
bouche comme ça des seins à l'air moi je
suis d'accord avec toi alors
mon enfant peut-être que je l'enverrai
pas faire cette lecture je m'en fous je
suis pas en train de dire il faut il
faut c'est pas du tout ce que je dis
c'est pas moi je m'en fous je regarderai
pas parce que mes enfants ils auront pas
besoin de ça tu vois ils ont pas besoin
de ça pour être ouvert d'esprit mais
s'il y a des familles ça ils savent pas
comment faire et que ça peut leur
permettre de vivre un moment d'ouverture
d'esprit et tout bah pourquoi pas c'est
tout ce que je dis mais sauf que Hugo là
je suis franchement là vraiment je
trouve qu'il a il a très bien résumé en
réalité malheureusement elle représente
quand même une partie de la société une
partie de la jeunesse encore une fois
c'est un épi il y en a il y a combien de
Drag Queen en France
j'ai quatre personnes dans ma famille de
Drag Queen
le traitement il n'est pas
proportionnelle
qui qui sont en mode télé-réalité donc
ça veut dire il y en a plus que des drag
queen c'est plus représentatif de la
société malheureusement
c'est lui il pensait que son slip il dit
oui je vais jamais lécher brand par
contre les modes de télé-réalité j'ai
pas envie j'ai pas envie d'en DM 1 et
qu'elle me dis ouais tu as muscu t'a dit
et puis c'est un petit milieu arrête de
penser avec ton slips vulgaire c'est
vulgaire mais en fait la vulgarité
pardonnez-moi c'est totalement
subjective je peux être vulgaire Kelly
peut être vulgaire ça dépend
pas toi tu préfères te voir toi à la
maternelle que des drag queen excuse-moi
c'est une femme
une drag queen sans contact avec un
enfant dans la vraie vie donc une
situation
quelle boulangerie ou dans la rue tu as
croisé des dans la Flûte Enchantée
comme ça 84 % en train de monter le nom
n'empêche on est à 13 au début
c'est les gens sont fous de complètement
jusqu'au Willis ils ont leur propre
voix de quelqu'un dans sa télé